Oh come on, i got 35... *sCREAMS*
[Jazzy music plays]
Oh. This is lovely, I'm happy about this.
Krampy, Krampy Krampus, Krampy, the Krampy Krampus.
Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to Krampus is Home, or Krrrompus or Kurrrempis
Krrrrumpus or Krampus, Krumpus
Krampus, why did the music-ugh
Ah. I don't like that.
Alright, so this is a horror game about Krumpus. Oh-hh, *laughs*
Okay, *deep inhale*, right.
I see what you're going for here. I see what you're doing. I don't remember my mic stand being this squeaky
*squeaky squeaky*
When I squeak on it. Oh, what a lovely setting for a horror game.
Oh, please tell me that's me!
All right, well this is awkward...
Uh oh *laughs*
uh oh
Huh. I'll just break my neck turning around there
All right. I don't know what movie that is, but I'm pretty sure it's not this game's movie. So....
Okay, whatever. I don't know what that is. Probably can't look at it because probably copyrighted
I was just watching the movie for a second there. All right, what was that thing I saw outside?
I guess I can't even go look. I can't- I- I'm not allowed out of the house
My parents said I was in timeout. Been a bad boy.
This is an awfully big house for me living by myself, and that's an awfully big dining table (cuts) for me living by myself
So you want to explain what's going on when I'm living here by myself?
eating me some
*laughs* Brixx
*pressure cooker sizzles*
Oh.
Okay, can't do nothing about that, I just got that on the pot for some reason.
Oh-
Ball, ball! Ball, ball, ball! Okay. Can I go out the front door at least? Can I see what's going on out there?
Do I have any objective at all? What am I doing?!
*narrating* "Pretty sure I saw something move on the back (cuts) Terrace. I better check!"
Okay. Well, I'm trying!
Do I gotta go back upstairs or something?
*character breathing heavily*
Oh, I'm all tuckered
All right. So, how do I get to the back Terrace? Nope?
No
What was that? (cuts) What was the use- Oh, is it F? (cuts) Oh
There's something weird going on with the audio
It like, stops every once in a while. What is- was was that? Okay, whatever. Well, there's my bedroom
*sarcastically* So glad that I don't have any curtains on there.
So glad so many random strangers can just come up and watch me sleep
It's weird. I thought I saw something...
Huh? Oh, do I have a maze in my backyard?!
Is this what I'm- is this what I'm this is what I'm seeing? I'm the weirdo that has a maze in my own backyard? Okay.
Well, I'm glad this is happening. *phone rings*
Oh- Hi howdy, Hootie
Yes?
Hello.
Okay, I already knew about that- mom!
(cuts) you Crazy lady! You crazy, crazy lady, leaving the pressure cooker on like that. I can't believe you!
*narrating sarcastically* "It's pretty hot."
It's real hot!
Oh, god, it's so toasty!
*narrating* "It smells really good. (cuts) I think it's baked beans." *laughs*
(cuts) *inaudible* (cuts) Here we go.
Ah!
That should do it. The audio's being real weird.
What the fuck is going on- oh
*narrating* "Now that I'm here, I could turn on the Christmas tree."
Seems like a (cuts) action for me
*narrating* "Dear Santa, This year I have been a nice person."
"For Christmas, I would like a video game console-" any will do I don't have a preference- "and a new bike."
Okay, Santa, alright, you little scamp, you.
how do I (cuts) turn it on?
Ooh. I guess I just whispered sweet nothings into its ear. All right, that's a nice tree
That's a nice tree.
I'm real happy (cuts) bout that one.
I dont have any other goals in life besides those things that I just did!
Very...
Oh...
So I CAN open these!
Can I get out here?
*narrating* "I better stay inside. It's too cold outside."
Baby it's col-
What in the- what-
In what world is (cuts) a laundry room
There's only one- there's only a washer.
(cuts) Drying rack and a washer. I guess that's okay. All right, you know who am I to judge? Everybody lives their own life
I'm not the type to (cuts) judge. Let's go back to my movie and forget that everything ever happened here. All right
*narrating* "What's (cuts) that laying on the floor?"
What's what laying on the floor? What's what laying on the floor? What do you see laying on the floor?
*gasps out of excitement*
ooh
Crouching!
*narrating* "The deer hates to be ignored" *laughs*
Well, the deer is about to get a face full of fist, if you know what I'm talking about.
*narrating* "I'm gonna call my parents."
Mom??
Dad???
Mom and dad?????
*line ringing*
*mildly frightened gasp*
*ding*
*whispers* Okay.
One of the bedrooms, you say? What is that?
Oh
*narrating* "I'm starting to hear strange voices telling me horrible things. I don't know what to do about this."
I don't know what to do, either. I don't know what to do either.
I don't got no idea what to do. Hey, Krampus, I've been a good boy!
I've been a good boy. I've been a real good boy
I definitely deserve not to have my my toes ripped out from under my feet
I've been so good
Let me tell you how good I been,
*saucy music plays* let me tell you how good I'll be to you. That's a naughty thing to say
But yeah, hey, Krampus, whatever you into I just happen to be into the same things, Krompy
I'm gonna show you a good time if you leave me alone. I know that's counterintuitive
I- how can I show you a good time if you leave me alone?
But let me tell you, I know how to- I know how to-
*saucy music again* I know how to do things with my hands. Okay?
Well, I don't- problem number one, problem numero Uno, if it's in one of these bedrooms, I can't see what's in these bedrooms
*narrating* "September 29th, I love being alone, but sometimes it just does not feel right."
"I hope to find something interesting to do in this area." OoOh
(cuts) Hey, you're boring
What is wi- and the weird audio! Keeps cutting in (cuts) and out (cuts) like that!
oh, oh! *gasp*
Blue flashlight!
Equip...
Oh!
Well that's (cuts) much better!
What's going- hang on, let me- I want to see if this is actually a problem. Hang on
I don't know if that fixed it. I just restarted everything.
If it do it do, if it don't it don't, and there's nothing I can do about it now.
Oh!
Okay. All right. Check the fuse box. All right
What?
You want to run that by me again?
Huh? Okay, it's still weird, but it's- I think it's just part of the game. Hello?
Does anybody happen to know where the fuse (cuts) box is, because I for one do not
I guess in the garage maybe? Or-
Oh no in the laundry room with the weird laundry (cuts) room. That's right
ah
Where's the fuse box? That's not the fuse- that is the fuse box. Okay, much better
Mucho better. All right, okay, we're gonna live! we're gonna live!
Wha-?
*stuttering* Huh? Bu- whi- wai- I- whi- um- uh- hi
Hello. Hi. Hello, Rudolph. How yo- how you doing? *narrating* "The elf hates water."
Great for the elf!
*narrating* "I think I have a water gun in the tool-house (cuts) -up." Oh, oh
Oh
Oh, oh, I see what you do- I se- I see- I see what you do. I'm trying to open this door. Oh, oh
That was a bit too close for comfy. Uh- red light, green light! No, I mean, sorry- green light, red light!
Ohhohohoh
I don't like you!
*narrating* "Flashlight's almost dead. I need to turn it off to save batteries, or find new batteries."
How do I turn it off?
I don't know how to turn it off. Hang on- um, unequip. That's annoying
Okay, right. You,
You just- ah, the tool sheds over here, I think? You just
Wh-yyyyyyyy
Did you get to do that? Don't like that don't like that don't like that
Okay, open. *narrating* "You find a key to open-" eh- fin- *mockingly* find a key in the kitchen, of course! Of course!
Where did the deer go?
Well, I guess the deer- Oh
I See
In the kitchen. The kitchen. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah yeah of course, I know- *gasp*
Hey bubba. Hey, hey bubba
Hey Bubba. Hey, don't worry. I'm looking at you. I got ya in the corner of my eye
You're in the corner of the apple of my eye
your Apple-y in the-
key in the
Hey, hey back up back. The. Eff. Up. Right. Now. No, you no
You don't get to do- you don't get to do that. You don't get- okay. Let's just play a little game. I like to call
"Stay the hell away from me." It's a fun game for the whole family to enjoy
you're gonna- ohh
I'm gonna get this- Oh, I don't know where the key would be
They said (cuts) kitchen, but I think they're full of lies
I'm gon touch your butt
Do it, touch your disease-ridden, bumpy butt.
I can't get a good look because this ass-
Whoa
Okay, give me a second give me a second give me a goddamn second. In the fridge? "I don't feel hungry."
Oh, I wonder why? Maybe because I got this demonic little-
Little piece of- Oh, you went that way. Okay, that's fine. It's not here. The bitchin' kitchen don't have no key
Let me go back outside. Let me make sure it actually did say kitchen
And also I like how my first instinct after I get a note is just like "I gotta go get my water gun!"
Oh, it doesn't like water. Oh, I'll get my water gun. Then everything will be perfect.
It said somewhere in the kitchen.
So it is somewhere in here. Just don't know where.
Oh! There there there- see it?
Got it. Okay. I got that
So that's good
And now I can just go open it and everything will be fine and everything will be great and everything will be wonderful
Why why who where why who where and why I don't see nothing
bOING!
I didn't see nothing. Why you gotta be doing anything to me. Don't be doing anything to me. Don't be turning lights on and off
God, we need to fix the foundation in our house. Okay?
F?
Okay, here we go, that's awkward, okay open-y says-a-me
Okay, let's open this
Okay. What are we looking for here? We're looking for a water gun of some type, right? There's batteries
Cool, any more batteries in here?
Probably not.
Okay. That does work, okay, let's put this away, I'm probably gonna need it in just a second
Oh, yeah, the- the number one line of defense!
A water gun!!
A water gun! Oh, I got batteries in my hand. All right. Well, that's useful probably
Okay, um,
*extremely scared gasp* I- what whas- thaat??
It's the deer! *narrating* "Yesterday, when I was in the backyard"
"I saw silhouette of something that looked like an animal. Was it real?" Are these my notes?
Okay, listen friend, you know, oh
(cuts) I- I guess??
It's not what I was trying to do, but okay. You just carry on, you have a good day now, Did he leave?
Why
Wh- Oh!
Ohhhh
Ohhhhhhh
OhhhHHhh
*screams
Okay
All right, this is problem. This is problem. This is a problem.
I gotta solve the mystery of whatever the hell's happening in my goddamn house
Yeah, it's all a nightmare. I can't wake up from okay
Psoosh, oh
pSOOSH! psoosh! psoosh! psoosh! "I should recharge it"? What does that mean? Oh, I'm gonna getcha- no- oh, no no no- I'm- *inaudible Markisms*
Oh, oh
You're quite ugly
I don- why did I have to head to the gazebo??
Why did I need to go to the gazebo?
Oh
(cuts) "At the back of the house. I'll be safer in there." Oh, yeah
Oh, as we all know, the one source of safety in this world; The Gazebo!
All right, oh there was a light fucking (cuts) me
*laughs* Ohhh god
You (cuts) dick! You (cuts) dick! You big dick! you big (cuts) floppy dick. Imma be ready for you this time
You ain't gonna get the jump on me twice
Alright put this away. Get ready here. Come on here. Come at me. Come at me. Come at me, bro. Come at me, bro
Where you at, bro? Oh, there you are. Oh, you aim and shoot. Oh, no, you didn't get me you got got instead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, where you going? Yeah, nowhere. Stupid. All right. So Hey, oh, what'd ya think you're doing? Sgoosh
Sgoosh, I said! Is this where the gazebo is? I don't know if this is the way to the gazebo (cuts) or not,
Oh, god, oh why did (cuts) mom and dad why did they have to build this maze? Oh, here we go
Gazabo. Doesn't help me, bench. How many- how many makeout benches do you need in a maze?
How much action did they think their son was gonna get? The answer is none! I'm alone
Alright, gazebo, "I see another note on that table." Okay, "You are coming with me."
I don't think I am
Stranger danger. I am NOT coming with you. I need to talk to my parents and tell them what's happening. Mom, dad
You won't believe it! A reindeer got it and an elf is chasing me
Some neighbor- aaHHH! God!
Fuck you!
You sneaky bitch! Alright, fine then-
How did you solve my parents maze? Okay, call parents again? Yeah. Yeah. I'm on it. I'm on it
I haven't recharged my gun, but I'm on it. Don't you worry about a thing. Let me worry about things
You worry about being an asshole Skoosh, okay
Why I am I so shaky? Is this refilling it?
I don't know if that's refilling it.
I'm gonna assume that refilled it. Here we go! Oh, well, that's a problem
Crawl in through the window, maybe?
Ooh! (cuts) Jump!
Ooh, got 'em. Got 'em. They think they got me, they do not
Hi, nope, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
No- Mom, dad, deer- deer problem
(cuts)
*narrating mockingly* "Please come back now! Weird creatures are chasing me!"
Thanks mom and- see, I knew that was  gonna go over so good! My parents, they-
They- *babbling* my parents never listen to anything I say!
What kind of parents wouldn't (cuts) believe (cuts) their own (cuts) child?
Weird (cuts) things are happ- uh oh
I just got survived I can camp out in this corner. I'm a camping bastard
Oh- oh- uh- uh I don't wanna do this- not Bambi. No. Bambi, No! I'll do it. Oh you make me do it, you know, I'll do it to you
Give me a- gimme me a reason. Gimme a reason. Gimme an excuse. I'm gonna do it. I'm gonna do it
Imma do it! Imma do it!!
Don't look at me in the eye like that!! Okay, whatever. I'm gonna get out of here
Wha- wait.
Wha- wh- who did that?
Who's that? I got water pistol.
I got a water pistol. Oh, oh, oh that's a problem. Let me go ahead and combine. Ooh shit
What the-?
Alright. Okay Krumpy.
Alright, Krumpalucious.
*inaudible frightened babbling*
Hey, whoa, I got a water pistol! I got a water pistol! I'll spray you, bitch! I'll spray you, bitch! I'll spray you, bitch!!!
Oh- h- what the fuck?? What're ya- what're ya- don't grab- ohh.
*light sobs of defeat*
Okay, I don't know how to beat that!
All right, so what am I supposed to do (cuts) when Uncle Krumpus
Decides to come knockin? I bet he can't climb in a window
So what I gotta do is I just gotta stay outside by this window when shit goes down
Which it will. Come on, you bitch. Come on.
Alright Krumpy. All right. Where you at? Where you at? Ah, I'll do it. You wanna do it?
I ain't scared. You scared. Come on, baby
Give me a reason give me a reason
Give me a reason to do this. Oh shit. Okay, you...?
Are fine, okay
It's all good, baby. No one will know no one needs to know no one cares
*excited gasp*
Flying elf!
Magic is in the air!
Beauti- oh, what a beautiful deer. Oh, hi elf
No, no
*laughing* what the fuuu-dge???
What the fudge! What the Christmas cracker? what the tinsel is happening here
Rub peanut butter on my tinsel. I'm really really not sure (cuts) what's happenin
Oh, hey. Alright. Listen, that's a good thing you don't see me, cause boy, howdy this would be awkward
I'm pretty sure I can just camp here!
Think I could just camp here I'm pretty sure this is gonna work. I'm a genius everybody else is stupid
I'm a smarty they're dumb.
I'm genius. if this is a top-level- I- 800 IQ gameplay right here, Let me know down the comments below. Smash that like button
*gaSP*
It's the most incredible thing you've ever seen. That's right, you better run away, you know how to smash that bell
Ringaling that bell. Jingle bell that Bell because it's time to bring it on
*laughing*
Schoosh! Oh get me with that stupid
Maybe that was a dumb idea. Maybe that was dumb. Unlike this idea of hiding
(cuts) behind one pillar which is (cuts) smooth to the UNTH degree. Okay, it's twelve- oh, god
It's only 12:55!
Deer and
Elf they're just really floating by that window. They- they smell me. They definitely smell me
AH they're still there! Just one more hour to go. I- probably a checkpoint, you know, probably a checkpoint. It's one more hour
That's all I got to do. Just one more hour. It's easy
Surviving is easy!
*Scared gasp* *whispers* No
You're real jumpy. Ooh, you're jumpy and frumpy, don't you think about it! This is MY hiding spot!
*more inaudible markisms*
OHH MY (cuts) GOD
OH
Don't get me just because I'm screaming from behind this pillar doesn't mean that you get to get me. Alright, man
I'd be bad in a (cuts) horror situation. I'd be I'd be in a hay bale. Totally safe. No, no noise there
I should be screaming at the top of my lungs when the villain comes by
I have the worst instincts of the history of ever
I don't wanna do nothin'!
I don't wanna do this!
I'm gonna try to stop being such a bitch baby even though this is like, pro level strategies here I'm o- I'm gonna make laps (cuts) around (cuts) the house
Just because I don't want- I don't want nobody at home thinking that I'm not actually a top tier
100% player of this game
Which I is
Obviously
so- it's a bad idea- IT'S A BAD IDEA
OH! KRUMPY! THAT'S MY WINDOW! (cuts) What did you sit on the ground over there?
Is that my present? For me? Krumpy, is that my present? Is that my Christmas present? You re- you 'membered!
You remembered! I can't believe you, Krumpy. Why did you leave a present for me?
You shouldn't have! You shouldn't have, Krumpy! Who's a lumpy Krumpy?
Who's a Krumpy lumpy? I want that present. Oh, it's gone. You took it away!
You bastard! Okay, let's see if, um... Turn on the light... (cuts) *gasp*
*whispers* did you see? AH HE SAW HE SAW HE Saw he saw
The news flash, he saw! He saw. Okay, if I jump in through here- Oh, Oh bad! Bad! Um-
I should have stayed in my hidey hole
I should just stayed in my hidey hole. Turn this off cause I don't need it. Think about it
*extremely frightened Mark noises*
I can't run- AH! Ah, fuck. It's not fair.
R- oh, really?? Oh, just one more hour to go, *crying* I thought it was gonna put me all the way back
*sobbing* I'm going out the window
Gonna go back to my hidey hole (cuts) cause it works. This worked. This works. Nobody knows I'm here
Everybody (cuts) knows I'm a cool guy, (cuts) but nobody knows I'm here and I think that works to my advantage
Cause as so long as they know I'm cool, they're not gonna come bother me. And so long as I stay behind this pillar
I'm gonna keep being happy. Does that make sense? Yeah
Who did you why
Oh, oh- Okay, he's gone. I don't know what that noise was but, ooh, I didn't like that.
1:15? It's only 1:15?
Hey, you know what time it is? 1:15! Time- for you to go- Oh dick poopy
*gasp* Hi thumpy Krumpy
Krumpy's a-thumpy-en! Krumpy's a real thumpy-
*Scared noises*
Whoa, Krumpy's a real thumpy!
*nervous laugh*
*nervous noises*
*grunting?*
Come on, I got 35- *screams*
I DIDN'T (cuts) *inaudible*
I'm never gonna beat it! I'm never gonna beat it. I'm never gonna- there's no- it's physically impossible. How could anybody beat this?
Nobody could. Nobody could ever beat this!
It's impossible! One more hour!
Okay, I know I might have let my guard (cuts) down (cuts) for like half a second but (cuts) listen (cuts) Krumpy lumpy, Krumptastic,
Mr. Krump- can the audio please just stop freaking out (cuts) for a few seconds
I just got to keep- I don't know how to get rid of Krumpy
I don't think spraying (cuts) him's gonna work
And I'll try spraying him with every fluid I have in me but somehow (cuts) think it's still not gonna work
Oh
Okay, he's right there. He doesn't see me though. Okay, so he might be coming out here
I just need to be mindful and he might be coming right around this corner, but I think I can wrap around this pillar
No problemo. Oh
Here he comes. Okay. Watch this pro- pro level moves pro
Pro, pro pro pro
Bro which way you going bro? Which way you pro go- *gasp*
Okay, pro, pro, pro, pro
He came right to where I was, Krumpy knew. Man, I didn't know the game developers programmed
(cuts) Real, honest, true, (cuts) artificial (cuts) intelligence in this game, but man, boy howdy they sur-
They sure did. What time is it? M- cock- It's cock o' clock
Oh shit. Okay, that's an issue
Okay, 1:30 30 more minutes. That's all I gotta do
krUMPY
Krumpy, you frickin bitch
yyyoooooouuuuuuu
Fudgin bitch. Nice in the kitchen ris- *GASP*  No, no, no. No. No, not you
Not you not like this not like this not like this, please
(Deer Noise, sharp gasp) OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, Okay, here just. Shut. Up. Don't. Mo-
*Screams*
Fucking GAHHD
*sigh of defeat*
So we're gonna play that game are we
We're gonna play the game with you're a giant douche to me and I gotta just sit there and take it
I just gotta take it and take it you're douchiness. I just gotta take it take it and take it
I gotta eat it up eat
Eat eat eat it up. I'm not gonna do (cuts) I'm done (cuts) poopie. The poopie is done being eat (cuts) me
I'm not eating anymore poopie from you guys. Not this time
Not ever the poopie eating is now done forever and tomorrow and today no poopie you ask me
(cuts) Poopie I say NO. I SAY NO TO THAT.  you offer me a ball (cuts) of poopie in my cereal. I say NO
Not anymore! Yesterday, Sure, I'd be slurping down that bowl of poopie in no time
But now no, no I'm a big boy now. I'm a big boy with big boy drEeEeams
And Imma show you how much I'd not eat the poopie you hEAR ME
You hear me you thumpy krumpy bitch. I'm not eating your poopie. I've had enough
So why don't you just take your poopie and you shove it back up where you got it from?
No-
Don't do that
Not like this
Not like (cuts) not at 1:20 a.m
The only time in my life when I'm poopy free, I lend you poopy, man
I will with my gun filled with mystery fluid-- *Giggles*
The only thing that can defeat the poopy. Oh, okay
I guess I'll leave I'll guess I'll leave then. My gun is useless on you. My gun sure is useless
G-Going away?
*Whispers* Ok
*More whispers* Rush back to my spot
*extremely frightened gasp*
That's quite a thump
Ooh!
Okay, I think I'm good 1:30, 30 minutes. That's all it is
30 minutes 1:30. Okay. I'll admit it's no longer- poop free o'clock down miss
Eh, Okay, I think he's coming out
He might be coming out front, front way. This leaves me exposed to Mr. Elf man with the window closed,
I think that maybe Elf man might not be flying out.
*gasp* Oooh he is. Okay. He's coming. Here. We go evasive maneuvers. Perfect
*gASP*
(cuts) Play action here.
Perfect play action, the ultimate moves
*Gasp* No don't do.. no
No
What're you doing? Should we go-
Oh yeah, no. Let's not open that one.
Let's actually close that
No
Okay, I'm gonna close that
Cause I don't want nobody floating out here
That was loud. Maybe he's drawn to loudness.
Maybe me screaming about poopy at the top of my lungs didn't do Krumpy no good
(Gasp) Okay what time is it- 1:40, 20 minutes, 40, 20. That's easy.
Hello floaty man
Wha?--
What'd you do?
Huh?
Don't do that. Okay
Twen- ten minutes. Easy.
Easy, no problemo
*Gasp* Ok here he comes, here he comes, here he comes, here he comes
*frightened gasp*
Okay. Alright. Pro-- Pro moves, pro moves.
*GASP* Pro moves, pro moves. Pro. Moves, pro moves. Pro. Moves. Pro.
I am-
The ultimate Krumpus is Home player in the world top, rank one. No one better.
No one better
No one ever gonna be better. Setting down a present ain't gonna do you no good- yet you come back, you come back, Krumpy
You come to my house and you try to tell me how to live my life
The Answer, Mr. Krumpus, if that is your real name
*Big Gasp followed by even more weird breathing noises*
Mom, dad, I didn't eat the poopy! Oh--
Oh.
*Laughing* Oh, ok.
"Looks like he learned his lesson after all" *Laughs* looks like it's gonna be a Merry Christmas *More laughs*
Okay, all right
What's happening now? What is happening? Oh no
Now I sleep with my water gun under my pillow
Oh no
*Laughing* Oh no
Uh-oh *giggles*
Ohh no *Laughing*
All right, okay, you really got me that time.
Oh no
Loading *laughs*
Oh, go-- What is this?
What is that? (cuts) What's happening? (cuts) Where am I?
I won't eat it. I won't eat it!
You can't make me! I won't do it! *giggles*
I am a man of my word and I will not, I refuse.
Oh boy
Where am I? I'm in a prison? I'm in a prison!
I'm in a prison.
Oh boy.
Yep, I sure AM in prison. Well,
I shouldn't have skipped out on (cuts) the poopy *laughs*
I've committed the worst crime known to humanity.
Oh boy.
*narrating mockingly* "What is this place? I have to get out here!" "Escape the cell." If only it were so easy"
Okay, um, I don't have time right now to keep playing.
So I'm gonna leave this one here for now. I'm sure that there's a- a
Probably a very in-depth ga- ooh!
I love vaporwave!
That's it for now, so thank you everybody so much for watching,
Let me know what you think down in the comments below. I am off back to Cincinnati for Christmas,
So videos are gonna be a little sparse here and (cuts) there, but, I'll be live-streaming a bit more,
I'll be recording videos with my family, with my mom, and, uh, everybody over there.
So thank you everybody so much for watching. And as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*outro music*